- I love that you write a book
and you get to like, go all
over New Zealand, right?
Like for this book?
- Yeah, right, yeah.
I went to New Zealand,
traveled all over the islands
and it's kinda like Peter
Pan's world honestly.
It's got alpine, it's got glaciers,
it's got amazing
mountains, fjords, jungle,
flightless birds, great white sharks.
There's so much to do there.
It really is an incredible place.
- It's beautiful.
I remember the first time
I went there, I was like,
"Why do I not live here?"
- [Guest] Right?
- Yeah.
- Parts of it remind me of Scotland.
It's got a real Scottish connection.
That's kind of the reason I went there.
But it is mountainous.
It's an epic, epic country.
- And you are the person that goes to,
I'm the person that goes to a place
and like enjoys the scenery.
And you're a person that
adventures around, right?
You do all the things that might kill you.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah
- Yeah, yeah, I dived
with great white sharks.
I jumped off cliffs.
They have, obviously, they
invented bungee jumping
in New Zealand.
- They did?
I didn't know that.
- They invented zorbing, if
you don't know what that is.
- What's a, what?
- It's a big ball that you climb inside
and then rolled down a hill.
It sounds terrible.
It was great fun.
- It sounds like the worst ride at a fair
is what it sounds like.
- Yeah, it's pretty much
you then can fill the ball
with water or gin maybe,
or Whatever you want, you can
- Now you've reeled me in, okay.
All right.
Well, I heard that the
forward is Peter Jackson.
That's amazing, "Lord of the Rings."
So, did you meet while you were there?
- Sure, Peter Jackson.
No, we didn't meet him, unfortunately.
But, you know, my co-star Graham,
he had worked on "The
Hobbit" many years ago.
I was possibly named after a Hobbit.
My brother was named
after an elf in real life.
So I was like, "This is meant to be."
So we went to Weta where they
build all of the animatronics
and the aesthetics
and they actually made
me up to be a creature
from "Lord of the Rings" and "The Hobbit."
Unfortunately, it wasn't
an elf, it was a dwarf.
I got to play Growing the dwarf.
- Okay.
- And it was quite a transformation.
- I know, wait, I wanna see the picture.
'Cause it is quite the transformation.
- [Guest] There he is.
- Yes.
That guy is not picking up
a lot of women in New York.
(Kelly laughing)
- [Guest] Oh, I dunno.
- I mean, well maybe a particular kind.
- [Guest] Yeah.